oh hey didn't see you there best intro
ever
you got it so many viewers have asked
the question how do you get this opengl
thing going these days
well i'm going to show you in the
quickest easiest
way i know how so strap on your boots
and put your saddle on leather straps i
don't
what am i even saying anymore all right
let's get some opengl going easy mode
quick mode awesome mode c plus plus mode
you got it
as you see it's uh don't look at this
let's just let's just open a new one
okay new project brand new fresh project
empty empty project let's go we're gonna
call it
open asdf that's that's the title well
that's a terrible title
opengl demo oh the best title
the best title you can't get any more
original than opengl
demo can you is that impossible
okay i'm a little big over here maybe
i'll just shrink myself how's this
you guys still see me no too small okay
we'll
we'll find a grit a good level find a
good level maybe about here code's not
that important it's all about me
right is that just kidding all right all
right i know
i'm mocking other youtubers okay i can
do that a little bit right is that is it
cool if i do that actually i feel like i
should just
i should decide my face now well too bad
it's staying i make the decisions
around here all right so new project
there's nothing in it we haven't done
anything we just opened
an empty project so we got x86 debug all
right
cool so what do we need we want to get
opengl going easy first of all let's
make
a source file right over here whatever
that's fine just we just need a c plus
plus file of any sort and we're going to
go
include glw oh it doesn't seem to exist
that's because
i haven't grabbed the libraries for the
x86 versions because
only noobs work in x86 we're going
straight to x64
and of course i have that library ready
to go oh darn you're stuck
you're like i don't have this library
ready to go go watch this vc package
manager tutorial there you go now that
you're all caught up to speed
let's continue shall we uh here we go
so there we go we included that seems
sort of happy well okay we're going to
be relying on
visual studios uh syntax helpers and it
doesn't update you hit the save button
oh it's gl w3 yeah i need that i i need
that all right glw
three and we need a main and we'll do
this standard thing here because
we have a reason it's not necessary but
uh there we go
you'll see all right so there we go
that's pretty standard thing we got glf
w3 because that's how we're going to be
doing our windowing and we're going to
putting our opengl context
into glc3 gfw3 is a windowing system
there are tons of windowing systems
tons of them italia let's let's have a
gander some of them shall we shall we
okay well here we are if you just have a
general look at my upside down face
you'll see
that i have brought up this this website
hold on
there we go on kronos.org beginner
frameworks
all right so let's talk real quickly
about these different frameworks
because these are sort of important and
if anyone asks why there's an upside
down guy on your screen just just make
them subscribe just go go here and click
the subscribe button okay
i that's that's all i have to say all
right beginner frameworks we have
whatever they're talking about up here
unofficial opengl sdk
collection libraries okay beginner one
shot section multiple tools i haven't
actually used these graphic in physics
framework
uh these might be cool to check out
sometime but uh let's look at the
context windowing toolkits
because that's where we're using glw3 is
a windowing toolkit
and uh there are a bunch of others just
free glut i've used frigala before it
seems like glfw
is better in every way so i use glw
generally glass very old do not use
perfect
perfect description best description um
and there's some other ones too some of
these are pretty cool you can look up
like demos
and games that are made with these
allegro sdl sml
they're used a lot in game development
especially older games i don't know if
they're used a whole lot anymore now
that
everybody just uses and we have some
tool kit windows that you can put opengl
context into and now i know you're
confused it's probably your
like opengl context what you mean it's
just like the space that opengl renders
to that it tells your video card to do a
thing here
on your screen so that's a very quick
description of a rendering library or
video in general
but it's it's pretty much true okay we i
got sidetracked we've also got
qt which you know is decent i've used qt
it's nice for making tools and stuff
with c plus plus and yeah you can do
open
wx widgets i haven't used it but i've
heard good things game gui i haven't
heard of this one
let's have a gander shall we baserat
game gui i don't know
all right whatever all right so there
you go that's the stuff
back to your regular scheduled coding
all right here we have a main and uh
yeah we got to get some stuff going so
all we got is this plain old source
so the first thing you would need to do
with glsw is initialize initialized so
we're just going to dl w3
and hit and that's just a function from
glw3
that should initialize it and this does
return a value a true or false
returns true you're good so we're just
going to not whatever it is
and we'll throw maybe actually you know
we i
i don't think you actually need to do
this it's
i'll show you in a second bro failed to
init oh w all right well there's another
cool thing you can do with glfw before
you start initializing it
and it's you can set error callbacks
which is very cool you just uh
you just do it you go jfw3 set error
all back i think that's right yep and
you got to give it a function it does a
thing whenever there's an error
so we'll do error fallback
i'll i'll call it glw error all that and
we got to build this function but let's
not do it in this file
let's just make another header file
because we want these callbacks to be
static so we can just put them in a
header and that would be super easy
header
we'll just call it callbacks cool sounds
good we'll just go
static void name of that function
and uh we'll just grow um
you know w error i think this actually
takes
something once a signature of some sort
so
there's going to be a lot of these
functions and be honest if i go
off the knowledge in my head i will
blunder some of them because there's a
lot of different signatures a lot of
things you got to remember
so sometimes this syntax will help you
can highlight your function or whatever
and it'll tell you what you need but in
this case it just says callback and it's
not
quite enough we got to go look at that
glfw error function all that
or we could just look at the
documentation so i'm going to show you
the documentation
and this is something you'll need to
know going forward because it's always
handy it's always
that's why click pause guys just a quick
pause no
not an advertisement just something you
need to know it's just in case you don't
look it's actually rather important that
uh you have video drivers for opengl or
it's just not going to work so if you're
using like a weak
chromebook or laptop that has intel
graphics drivers
all right to be honest this this skip is
usually this
skip this step is usually skipped for a
reason that's because
your automatic updates generally handle
this but in some cases they won't so you
need to know about
things like downloading opengl all right
so generally the vc package manager is
going to handle that on windows but you
need to have drivers
and you're going to have these if you've
got up-to-date drivers for whatever your
video card is
you should have these just in case you
don't and you're totally stuck being
like i don't have drivers
go here it even talks about linux stuff
so this one is more likely to come in
handy because some linux distros
don't detect video cards right first
time or something i'm not sure
it's uh a little more standard on
windows right now you just get the web
updates and
they yell at you if you're missing
anything critical hopefully anyway
but linux doesn't necessarily do that so
much if you've got specialized hardware
all right
well now that you know that um let's get
out of this quick pause
and go somewhere else where was i oh
yeah
callback callback functions and glfw
documentation that's right
yeah excellent excellent post excellent
documentation cool documentation wow
you guys can't see where i'm clicking
because my entire body's in the way all
right here we go
documentation we're there it's all it's
all they got is here there's this
getting started guide glued initializing
setting a callback
so yeah you can get a lot of the stuff
that i'm going to show you here but
this is uh where you want to go if you
just get totally stuck or want to expand
beyond what you've understood so this is
your going forward guide basically for
glfw
here's the error callback hey there it
is we need an end error and a
description so it's going to have this
signature those
copy that awesome awesome
let's go to where the signature is just
put that right in there
hide the parentheses there we go and
since it's static it's only going to get
built
once and it's always going to be ready
and we can
uh stuff with this error number and we
can do some stuff
with the description if we need to so
what do they have what do they recommend
they recommend this just f print we can
do more than that we can do a little
more than that or why not have print
let's just do that
we'll also just throw sure because we
don't want to continue if we have an
error so we'll just go ahead and throw
right in our bad boy here
all right so that's how you set a
callback though that's the easiest way
you just make better build it in there
include it over here but of course we
gotta
include our callback header there we go
and it's ready to go so now if this
fails
we'll we'll get that call back so we
don't necessarily need to throw here
it's already just gonna throw for us
so um pretty cool i don't know if that's
like the best idea i don't know if you
should still check on legislation or
just expect this callback to handle it
but
it's just something you can do to
generally customize
stuff without having to if else all over
the place pretty handy if you ask me i
know what you're saying
right now hurry it up quit wasting our
time don't worry i'll cut this
i'll put some cats in but hopefully
hopefully this uh helps you stay
focused i don't know just my face all
over the place i guess
all right so let's get on with it let's
create a window we need a glw
window pointer to a window oh and then
we're going to initialize it i could
just initialize it right in line here
but i'm not going to
and well i guess the reason is
i don't know there's there's some reason
okay let's just do it
okay so glw functions start with the glw
and then you should be able to see their
signature once you start typing them
there we go
all right so we want width i don't know
let's just do 100
600 title yes title
monitor we can put no pointer in here
share we can put no pointer here for now
it's like options we're not using one of
them for
full screen one of them so which monitor
you're on okay
so we've got a window now we what we
need to do is we need to set the opengl
context
to this window and if this window has an
error this callback should detect it so
we don't need to check for no
window that's we already have that going
on right here
so what we're going to do here is just
make glw make context current and it's
this window
and then we're going to set that context
to whatever
our opengl handling stuff is so one
thing you can do
is you can say define this is for glw
for you about what is it glw i don't
know something
xt what i'm looking for maybe it's this
i don't
it's that's not right but we're not
going to do that instead we're going to
be using
that you can also install glad with
bcpkg but we just do
glad then we can say glad proc address
from glw ah
geez i gotta look this bunk up i don't
remember it's something like this though
okay
sometimes you just gotta copy pasta you
know sometimes you just gotta there it
is
okay so i think we've done everything we
need to do here to get the contacts onto
that window
got the window created we made it the
current context which basically means
that's the one we're working on
and then we loaded glads functions
point to it with this whole thing here
so now we can actually operate
um so basically we just want to go into
a while loop right
while and do what render yes exactly
precisely and to render you just do glw
swap buffers and on that window
and you also want to do glw events
and it's just like that this basically
picks up your mouse movements
key movements and any interaction with
the window so if you don't do this on
every loop then you won't be able to get
input from your main devices so got to
do this at the end
and this essentially just renders
whatever you put on the window for it
that's space so generally what you end
up doing here is
handling key presses um and then
updating your window
in the state of everything and then
swapping that to the front
with this swap buffers and that's
generally workflow but
we're a little ways away from that
because we're going to set up a few more
things but in general this is good
enough to to work like if we just hit
play right now this will actually
run or should there goes pops up a
window with titles just a
link window blank everything so let's
add a few more basics to this before
we end part one okay now one thing i
kind of really want to do is just drive
home the point of these callbacks
because we're going to be using them a
lot and it's very easy for them to get
confusing
you can switch between them on the fly
but you generally want to have some
default ones you load up so we're just
going to go into this callbacks and
we're going to make another function
for our closing of our window so in here
not we're not going to do while one
because
then we don't really have a good way to
stop program we're just going to use
something glw has which is geo glfw
window should close there it is
so now what glw windows should close
when we go past the window pointer
what this does is it doesn't actually
close your window it just
tells if a flag has been given that says
hey you need to close the window
so basically we want to get out of this
while loop if there's a
thing that says close and then we can
close our window and there's ways we can
do that
there's uh i think there's a glw little
window for example or whatever there's
one
but general we're not going to use it
we're just going to use the all-in-one
terminate of w terminate and then turn
zero because
we're in c plus plus into main in this
end
request that we return something so zero
zero is going to be fine we could uh
you know change that later if this is an
api where we want to return a proper
value but for now zero is gonna mean got
to the end of the program without crash
okay so we actually this loop we just go
ahead and terminate and we're done but
in theory you could
have other stuff here you could say okay
now let's open
let's delete all this window stuff make
a whole new one and open a new window so
you can have windows pop up one after
another and stuff like that you don't
have to terminate is the point i'm
saying here there's a lot of
creative functionality you can do with
this you can even have multiple windows
and
jump between contacts to do stuff so the
lfw
offers a lot of options for window
control and it's one of the reasons i
like it it seems to be pretty stable too
okay so back into our callbacks function
let's just make a function to put
in the close callback window close
callback yes there we go and this wants
a
window yeah that's all it needs okay so
always just be checking the
documentation for these signatures if
you're not sure
it will tell you right where i showed
you it is before so here we could do a
thing
like um they
what we'll just print f go close
which is pretty obvious but just to just
so we know our callbacks work
and we should see this message is the
point okay now we do actually have to
set the callback and generally you want
to set this callback before you go into
your loop
so we'll just do g alpha w set and
there's a window close
all back window
close callback there it is and it just
wants a function
since we have that new function built
we'll just reference it what was the
name of it when do it close callback
there we go that's our static one that
we built
and it doesn't seem to like it why
doesn't it like it because this takes
two things it takes the window as well
gotta go window or pointer to the window
and you can see that if you just hover
over this function at that point does
help you right there too handy things
about having a nice
ide they will save you a lot of time at
times
but don't don't be alarmed sometimes
they set you back too okay so we've got
a few callbacks in there let's say play
make sure it works
looks good let's close this says window
closed so use that callback
we didn't have any errors if we did have
errors we'd see this error callback
actually i can introduce an error so one
of the things you can do before you
create a window is you can set the
context it is prepared for
uh let me just do that real quick
something you can just paste in there i
want to give the window a hint for the
glfw context version major and minor
though when you go to set
uh glfw or when you go to set it up you
want to make sure
that it supports opengl 3.3 basically
and if it doesn't it'll throw an error
so it should be fine with 3.3
because i know that this particular
computer works fine with opengl 3.3
so no problem but if i set this to 4.7
which isn't even out there is no 4.7 so
this should throw an error
it basically will help you catch errors
with context seen
at launch as we see we threw an error
but if we go
back just a little bit before we go to
our command line whereas there we go
you'll see that it actually with that f
print right there it actually
sent this error driver does not support
opengl version 4.7 no driver will
because it doesn't exist
so as you can see it did exactly what we
wanted it through
it spat out the error all because we
have this callback having that context
check
i'm just going to leave a 3.3 for now
but if you want to check on your video
card this is something you can do
and you can loop and retry until you get
the right version if you want to have
like
super error checking but it looks fine
looks like i support 4.6 it did not
throw an error
so with this computer i can go ahead and
start programming with the latest openg
standard as you can see so just a cool
trick that might come in handy
and i'm going to show you just one more
cool trick
um that is super handy and it is to make
a utilities
area as well and do a similar thing so
let's just make a header called
utilities there we go and in our
utilities we want to have this functions
to help along the way that we
we might reuse a lot so for example you
see the window just has a title here
we could have this be the name of the
program that's in rb here
because you know anything about c plus
plus you know that rv
0 is a const character array that's the
name
of this so that's the name of this
program so if i run this
my my window title will have that see
here that it
it's awesome there it is all the way my
entire
directory so we can make a function that
extracts out just the last part of this
for example as a utility an example
utility and i'll just do that right here
go to my utilities
and i'll static turn across
care star extract version
and we're going to take a scare stoner
uh whatever it's called and we want to
end up returning
something that is just the extract
version we can do that real quick
actually build it just a moment before
hitting the old play button
we can do it with strings pretty easily
so we'll just do an include string now
this might be different
for linux it might be a bit window
specific but
okay we'll go like this i'm just gonna
do some copy and paste
and whatever i'll type it i can just
fast forward so we're just going to hold
a few variables now this is
terribly inefficient
but i'll explain why we're doing it the
way we're doing it how it works
okay like that
okay but we just want to get the last
part of that whole name of the program
so
we're going to set this string equal to
that whole thing and then we're going to
make a new static string clear
whatever from whatever it previously was
static course because we don't want to
have to reinstantiate it and we want it
to stay in memory because it's a const
error
that needs to be in memory otherwise
we're going to have to copy it so
a little inefficient because it sticks
in memory but more efficient if you call
this
a lot because you don't have to keep uh
redoing memory
anyway it could be better but this will
get the job done so
we want to go like this we're just using
substring here
and like that though it does exactly
what it says here
find last of the slash find the last
slash and then we want to go
up to well in substring this is how many
more spaces
and it's calculate two up to the last
dot so
if we go into our source instead of rv
zero here we put extract
version then we pass that rb0 get it of
course we need to include our utilities
and since it's only static functions in
there
it will be fine um as much as you want
all right and now we see the title was
just open gl so just an example
there something you'll probably do a lot
once you get to
going about making a program and doing
stuff is making utility functions make
your life easier
and let's go ahead and log some stuff
logging is pretty important you don't
want to be see out and over all over the
place
so let's just make a utility to write a
log
static cons now we'll do boyd here uh
write
log and we'll take pick a message
conspire star
message so what we want to do is we want
to write to a file that's just a
standard log
for our program so we're going to be
using of course upstream here we're not
going to be using the old c
uh file open in f open that's beyond our
2020. that's it's too long ago all right
that's what i'm trying to say
so our log stream or we'll just call it
uh logs
for log stream yeah that works
oh it's because we have included that
stream for file stream all those
libraries from the standard there we go
so then we'll just do we just need a
file name
logs.open and uh we can give this
whatever we want
we'll just call this uh logs where
our log which is called our log and we
need to give it a mode
so we'll just go with end we want to
make sure we append otherwise we're
going to keep writing over
stream and once you overwrite this
you also need to make sure you include
everything else you want we just want
out yeah okay and i sure hope you know
how to find the default documentation
or all the standard library i'm pretty
sure i say it in every video
but just in case you don't in cpp
reference
yeah it's this site they much got all
the standards
and i think i'm using c plus plus 14 but
your mileage may vary you can always
check what you're using by just going to
your
project right clicking it and going to
properties and then looking under
general you'll see c plus plus standard
language
uh you can see there's what i'm on all
right now might change if you're
watching this from the future
you can check and change it if you want
visual studio
all right so once we've got that open i
know i keep going on side
tangents but we can just we can just
write to this so we've opened it
and then we want to just push out a
message so we can just do it just like
the old uh
see out sort of style and just push out
that message and then we want to close
it logs.close and that's really that's
really it
now we can just use that to write
messages to a file and i'll just show
you that real quick
so say uh well let's just do a callback
we have either these callbacks
uh let's print the log so we'll go
right log
and whatever the description is that
should do it of course mutate include
utilities here and there we go it'll
just write it to that file and we can do
the same thing here with this window
closed
a window closed
now we could do other things for this
log like we could include the date stamp
time stamp we could you know refresh it
every new run and right now it's just
going to keep appending to this log file
but i'll leave
that up to someone else and leave a
comment if you do leave a like
but this is just like a getting started
thing so we don't see anything in here
close the window we don't see the window
closed in here anymore and that's
because it wrote it so to see that you
can just go to your
directory here on my solution open
folder and file explorer and this is
just where we
where we uh made our project you know
we'll see in our log file there that
we're writing to and if you open that
you will just see that it uh has the one
thing we wrote
you can just use that utility to keep
writing to that file you don't want to
use the terminal all the time this is
probably less efficient than the
terminal because i'm opening and closing
a file all the time but there might be a
better way
someone wants to work on that you're
welcome to do that but another thing you
can do is you can also
what i like to do is with a lot of these
type of things they can if
def debug so if you're in debug you want
to write to log
and then like uh else so maybe if you're
in release mode you don't want to write
anything
you just want to do nothing if someone
calls right log because you want it to
run fast
so then now if you build and debug
you'll get the log version and
build and release you'll get the right
log version that doesn't actually write
but it also doesn't have to open and
close
so that's one way you can take advantage
of this debug and release
all right well that's going to be it for
this video let me know what you want to
see in part two as of now i'm just going
to plan on start contacting some opengl
stuff in here and start talking all
about it peace out guys
see in the next episode don't forget to
not forget to
hit the like button bye
you